president trump is slamming joe biden
and accusing him of being a
puppet of kamala harris on the far left
he won't be president for three months
before the uh
wonderful kamala takes over with her
she's the most liberal person in the
senate she's not a socialist she's a
step beyond socialism as you know
it's such a crazy thing and take a look
and biden agreed to this with crazy
bernie because you know they have the
manifesto they've agreed to most of
these things
and it's going to cost more money our
country will be
a ninth world country not a third world
country a ninth world country
and proving trump's point radical
democrats including members of the squad
unveiling their vision for america
if joe biden wins in november it
includes
defunding the police free health care
and canceling
student loan debt all right dana so
another manifesto this one looks even
more radical than the other one
i understand the reason why you want to
get the far left excited get them juiced
for
voting for joe biden but at the same
time can't that backfire and
turn off all those voters in the rust
belt that they need i
imagine that jessica tarlov will say
that this is sub-optimal
and that they could have you know kept a
lid on it until november 4th
yeah and then if biden wins they can say
okay
now you're going to be ours if they lose
they can say
this is why because you didn't go far
enough left a good point um i also think
that it's very smart for president trump
to have that line of attack about kamala
harris being the next in line
i don't think she had she did not have a
great debate
she did fine like not a great debate and
i don't think a lot of people walked
away from that thinking
wow i really want to change horses here
midstream because i don't like any of
these policies and
in fact there are some polling today
it's amazing how people feel better
about almost every issue
when it comes to do you feel better off
four years
now than you were let's put that up
there yeah oh it was just from gallagher
sorry i didn't have
pretty big 56 said they're better off
yeah than they were
four years ago usually those are pretty
indicative of
the winner greg i'm sorry i was trying
to write a joke
is it funny well here's the deal okay so
i have some stuff to help with like if
these are some things for we were
talking about republican ads yeah they
should go hard on this go if joe biden
wins
the supreme court will be replaced by
anti-fog
abortion will become legal to age 75.
what i was writing a third one here's
the deal
i'm waiting for something big to happen
yeah right don't you feel like there's
something big i feel like okay so this
is
like the president getting coronavirus
wasn't big exactly
because you know why we're in this
two-hour movie and we're only at the
hundredth minute
we haven't hit the final twist so i
wrote some final twist
i'd like to hear that yes okay here's
the final nancy pelosi
is actually her son who runs a desolate
motel
and he's been disguised as her since the
1980s
living in the attic donald trump yes
turns out to be
barack obama's father who's been
secretly running
the rebel alliance oh god um
after many accusations of mail-in fraud
one of the experts opens up a ballot box
and finds
gwyneth paltrow's head oh my god and
then finally
joe biden is actually kaiser soze are
you okay
greg katie we actually got a friday
friday potentially
in the 80s why a preview of one of these
plot twists
i i think we're going to see hillary's
emails before the election didn't dana
get that
out of mike pompeo today and she got
that out of she got
that out of and we'll be talking about
that later in the show
right but i mean i think to greg's point
we don't know what's going to come next
can i actually name the movies i was
referencing so i don't get hate mail yes
all right the first one was psycho nancy
pelosi
donald trump barack obama that was star
wars remember
rebel alliance the third one was seven
when they find gwyneth paltrow's
head in the box and the last one was the
one of the greatest movies ever the
usual suspect okay
with stephen baldwin that is a good one
i'm glad to
i don't have as many movie references as
that but you know
i think that movies will be made you
can't do worse
movies will be made about what's going
on right now it's you know it's the the
truth is stranger than fiction and
there's certainly a long way to go i
know that democrats feel pretty
confident about the polling
where they are but there's a long way to
go three weeks until election day
a lot can still happen squad manifesto
could that help her hurt
is it my time to bed wet is that 5 17.
um squad manifesto i so
the truth of the matter is that joe
biden has not
been he's like rubber and the glue thing
right that they've thrown so much stuff
at him
like you have dementia you're a
socialist
and nothing has stuck because people
this is the advantage of being around in
political life for 47 years
because people know that joe biden isn't
a socialist and i
i like his new tack of saying i beat
bernie sanders and i beat him handedly
this wasn't like
oh he was within a couple points of me
and so i think that the squad can do
whatever they want and i i appreciate
the fact that aoc is on the
climate task force for instance and then
he's bringing in younger members
but nobody is now thinking oh it's not
going to be joe biden ilan omar
lives inside of joe biden and she's
going to pop out okay
[Laughter]
but when you said the thing about donald
trump was actually barack obama's father
i was like maybe people will stop saying
that he's not american if we have that
donald trump as his father
um i think it's fine it's a
it's fun everything is true what women
mean when they say fine yeah
but jessica i mean aoc has said we can
push joe biden to the left and you have
to remember that joe biden is going to
hire a government 30 000 people he puts
into
a number of positions he's going to
appoint a can a cabinet
and as dana was saying the left is going
to want something in return
if joe biden wins because they're the
ones who are swallowing the tough pill
of voting for him when they see him as
too moderate so they're going to want
some kind of
repayment for their loyalty to a
candidate they're actually not that
excited about
that may be but it doesn't change who is
going to be president and he has been
steadfast his people can push him around
then listen you're not persuading
millions of americans who
say i know joe that he's going to turn
into a green new deal medicare for
he did it in the primary he went far
left in the primary and he never came
back sure
what are you talking about he said he
was gonna abandon billion dollar tax
increases health insurance for illegals
that's pretty social